formerly a limestone mine this wine
cellar is almost 60 kilometers long
Donna Maria as she's known to her
colleagues has been production manager
here for more than 30 years
she knows the underground labyrinths
like the back of her hand she regards
each individual bottle as something
special
this will tie do you notice a salmon the
wine is like a person yang wine is like
a small child that is constantly on the
go
it may be an unsettled view it takes
decades for a vintage to mature at that
point bottles are turned to distribute
the yeast that is collected inside
almost a million bottles are processed
here each year dust is part of the
package
Russian customers like it Bart as
Moldova intensified its relations with
the EU Moscow responded by boycotting
wine imports from the tiny Republic
there's not enough EU customers to make
up for the shortfall Russia once had
been a reliable source of income I now
we have greater freedom but that means
we have to look for clients ourselves
the way things used to be wasn't bad
because we had a reliable revenue we had
fixed prices that didn't change much now
we have to calculate everything now the
price depends on the amount of labour
invested distilled off on the rhine
river
Jacque al has been doing his best to
place Moldovan wines on the German
market and was commissioned by the EU to
offer marketing advice to wine makers in
the Republic with 280 shops to his name
he is one of the biggest wine traders in
Germany but he doesn't stock a single
bottle from Moldova it is still seen as
wine for the masses too high in alcohol
too sweet and too expensive for what it
is and dusty bottles are not a sales
argument in Germany the a minor fantasy
they have this fantasy about old wine
cellars where wine is stored for a long
time but these days two thirds of wine
produced in the world has to be drunk
within three years get Hong Kong man
although wine is an important export
product for Moldova local vintners have
not yet managed to tap into Western
European tastes but they need to change
that if the Republic's economy is to
thrive in order to improve her chances
Dona Maria has started to grow more
popular varieties of grape from France
and Germany Merlot and Riesling - name
but - and that is not all that is new
she is also invested in modern
fermentation tanks all in a hope of
accessing lucrative EU markets
Coria sperm on panels allow champagne is
no worse than French champagne
even the French venters who came to
visit told us that they were really
surprised by our champagne because it is
such good quality and so full-bodied
gusta TV they don't want to stop
producing red wine either about to make
it worth their while what they really
need is a solid sales concept for
Western Europe